because Carla and I are through been
talking about let me guess who wants I
want that way actually you don't
oh yeah I do interesting it's not the
other way yeah kinda maybe I'm sexist
maybe that was just a sexist that's no I
I really want one but I think it was
more I think was more that you feel like
the nurturing one and you feel like the
nurtured yeah I I was more just like a
fear thing right if he wasn't going to
[Music]
get better
oh sure I was just afraid that my genes
are weak no my genes are weak my genes
are no no I have the weakest jeans I
have murderers in my addiction in my
family so to see a mental illness a lot
what do they say they say in a mental
illness and drug addiction don't run in
my family it gallops yeah that's me
I got everywhere I got but the way but
the thing is is that regardless of how
was born when whatever traits I had her
genes it was like I was conditioned by
my fucked-up parents yeah right so I
just feel like if we just use you mean
the tools you know because number one I
would never hit my kid and regardless
right right and my dad used to beat the
[ __ ] out of me right right so it's like
there's just certain things that I
believe that I can fix that is fair it's
like there on the one hand the trauma of
your past you feel like well Who am I to
raise a kid I have this [ __ ] up trauma
in my in my blood and in my cultural DNA
on the other hand it's like oh I've got
all this information of how not to raise
a kid and I feel like that like my mom
was the opposite she was like her her
abuse was Oh was too much lovingness it
was like she was like on top I always
described as that guy's mother yeah she
grew up I grew up with her sitting on my
chest that's how it was just like always
they're just like loving meat she used
to do this thing when I was smoking or
she would be driving and she would reach
over to Pat my leg like a loving Pat but
it wasn't a loving Pat it was a frisk
and she'd be she'd be like
pat pat and she feel the cigarettes
she's driving on the freeway Wow start
grabbing them to try to destroy them in
the [ __ ] car is like being in life
how old are you like 7 yeah 7 when I
started smoking like 16 17
yeah like 16 just things like that like
my brother had this crazy breakthrough
in therapy which I really impacted me
strongly it's like growing up my we
would tell my mother a need that we had
like you know like we're hungry or you
lied or whatever and she would respond I
love you and it was like that's not the
right answer
that's that's not even applicable to
what we're talking about like when he's
up against the corner or if something he
replies what I love you as like I hate
it it's one of the sorry Bob Bobby lives
me crazy but in a way it's so belittling
where it's it does make me feel similar
there's two options I love you shut the
[ __ ] up is perfectly adequate yeah you
prefer that oh you do yeah absolutely I
hate I love you it's a but but don't you
feel like we learned like just what
Bobby's saying like you could learn all
this information from [ __ ] up parents
like I wouldn't like I just there's so
many things I would never do to my kid
because I they were done to me and it's
obvious in retrospect do you think that
we could possibly overcorrect though cuz
I feel like that's what my mom did my
mom grew up very poor and there were
times when she's a one of 10 kids didn't
have a lot of food a lot of times her
son she told me like one time she was so
hungry and they didn't have food so her
mom gave her salt and water to kind of
bloat her stomach and feel it was one
time like her brother ate two three two
just had the flavor to the rice
oh [ __ ] like that so when she got to me
when she got need she didn't allow me to
feed myself it was always spoon fed
because she wanted me to meet all my you
know exactly and so I was spoon fed up
and
till I was almost 30 you know about I
know but you now you now know about
overcorrecting right hey guys I'm gonna
take a quick break to talk about one of
our favorite sponsors
[Music]